في يوم مليء بالفرح كان لابد من حضور
الاغنيه الاردنيه بقوه في حفل زفاف ولي
العهد الاردنيه الحسين بن عبد الله وزوجته
الاميره رجوان سيف رواد مواقع التواصل
تداولوا مقاطع لفقره تقطيع الكيك حفل
الزفاف مع اغنيه قدمها لاخوان التوام حسام
ووسام اللوزي المعروفان بفرقه اللوزيين
الاغنيه طبعا حملت اسم يبارقنا او بارقنا
العالي وهي اغنيه صدرت في عام 2007 واصبحت
احدى اهم اغنيات المناسبات الوطنيه في
الاردن الحاضرون في الحفل تفاعلوا مع
الاغنيه خصوصا الملك عبد الله وزوجه رانيا
اللذان صاعده او صعد الى مكان تقطيع الكيك
وصفق بفرح على كلمات الاغنيه
والاخوان لوزي فرقه تاسست قبل نحو 30 عام
وتنشط في مجال الاغنيه الفلكلوريه
والتراثيه
الاردنيه اليوم صباح العربيه هنا نستضيف
الاخوان اللوزي للحديث اكثر عن الحفل
الملكي ومشاركتهما التاريخيه في عرس ولي
العهد
[موسيقى]
الله معنا الان مشاهدينا من عمان الفنانين
حسام ووسام اللوزي اهلا وسهلا فيكم حسام
وسام معنا في صباح العربيه
صباح الخير لقناه العربيه ويشرفنا هذا
اللقاء حياك الله صباحكم يا هلا يا صباح
الورد طب انا مش عارفه يعني انا راح
اوجه واللي بحب يجاوب يجاوب منكم
حبيت اسال عن تمام اذا في نيابه اذا
حبيت اسال عن الاغاني التي خصصتها
للزفاف الملكي التاريخي هذا بعض الاغاني
كانت ايضا العالي اغنيه قديمه وليست جديده
ولكن لها باع طويل ومحبوبه اغنيه شعبيه
ومحبوبه بشكل كبير يعني اختياراتكم لهذه
الاغاني
لعرس مميز ومهم وتاريخي مثلا هذا
شكرا الك اسمحي لي من خلال قناه العربيه
باسمي واسم اخويا ارفع اسماعيل والتبريك
لجلاله سيدنا
وجلاله الملكه رانيا مناسبه زفاف ولي
العهد وكل عام وطنا ان شاء الله يديمه
والفرح والمحبه والسرور طبعا هي بيرقنا من
2007 هي طبعا من كلمات
الشاعر حبيب الزيودي
وتقريبا هي الاغنيه صارت بصمه اردنيه يعني
تنحط بكل المحافل الاردنيه بالافراح وكل
المناسبات الوطنيه
وصير تعرف يعني فرحتنا بولي العهد عمت
جميع مناطق المملكه من محافظات المملكه
جميعها وبيوتنا وكانت ابتسام موجوده على
الكبار وعلى الصغار فهذا فرح وطني طيب
وفرح تاريخي بالاردن
يعني خليني اسالك بانه بهذا الحفل يعني
الكثير غنوا في العرس الملكي ولكن
اللوزيين لما غنوا وصعد الملك عبد الله
وقطعوا هذه الكيكه شنو الاحساس ما هي
الرساله التي وصلت للناس
شلون شفتوا هذا الموقع والله الاحساس سيدي
هو والله موقف انه مشرف جدا وموقف مفرح
جدا لجميع شعبنا يعني الاردني والمتابعين
من خارج الاردن
سبحان الله يعني البروتوكول الملكي عالي
جدا بس يعني تواضع جلاله سيدنا او جلاله
الملكه وطيب ومتواضعهم وقد ما كان في يعني
نوع من الفخامه بالفرح قد ما كان في تواضع
وبساطه والتوفيق طبعا اكيد من رب العباد
اخذت صدى كبير هي اغنيه يا بيرققنا العالي
طيب
يدركنا الوقت
سالنا الفرح قالوا لمين قالوا لحسين عين
اليم
شي دقايق تمشي دقايق يا ثوب الابيض عارج
ولا الله ما احلاها الله محلاها بعيون
حسين الله محلاه زايد غلاها زايد غرامها
رجوى نشميه ما اكثر
ويا رجوى لبست فستان بلون الورده الجوريه
اهلها زينه العربان قهوتهم عدنيه يغني لك
عاصي الحلان وفيروز اللبنانيه
والرمش الاسود على العين والكحله رب
انيه الله الله عاصي الحلاني وفيروز
والفرقه اللوزيه
الله
اليوم اليوم حسام واسامه اللوزي خلينا
نقول بانه ما الذي يميز الاغنيه الاردنيه
حتى دائما ما نشوف والله حتى في بلاد
المهجر نشوف الاردنيين مختلفين باحتفالهم
بالاغنيه الاردنيه
صحيح صحيح سيدي الاغنيه الوطنيه هي تعبر
عن حب القياده الهاشميه
وصدقا يعني تنحط بكل المحافل يعني اي نجاح
حبيت اردنيه تنحط الاغنيه الاردنيه ولا
الاغاني فسبحان الله هذه يدل على حب للشعب
لا قيادتنا الهاشميه ودائما يعني نطلب من
الله يعني المحبه تدوم يعني بين شعوبنا
العربيه والفرح جميل يعني اكيد
طيب احنا ضايل معنا دقيقتين برضو حابين
نسمع منكم ما بعرف اذا يمكن نسمع بيركنا
العالي بيركنا العالي او اي اغنيه تانيه
انتم محضرينها يعني
جاهزين جاهزين تحبوا اغنيه تراثيه اردنيه
والاغنيه وطنيه على ذوقكم يلا على ذوقكم
الله يحييك اللي انتوا طيبين واحنا نستاهل
يلا
كل البنات
نجوم يا عنيد
والله وشوقك وما
عيني وما
عيني
ضلت تصبوا هالقهوه وزيدوها
للنشامى عبور الخيل بالله تصبوها القهوه
وزيدوها
للنشر عبور الخير لا تصبوا هالقهوه
واسقوها للنشامى ظهور الخير بالله تصبوها
القهوه وزيدوها
للعربيه ابو
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
وقهوتكم طيبه
قهوتكم طيبه الحقيقه يعني ولا اجمل
طيبه ونتشرف تشرب قهوتنا بالاردن والله
نشكركم
واحنا معازيبكم
وان شاء الله دياركم عامره دائما والاردن
ان شاء الله لنا
دائما وابدا العضاية
شكرا جزيلا لكما الفنانين حسام
والله
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات